la vigesimocuarta que en esencia de su
historia en el parlamento israelí
completó su disolución en un proceso
largo lleno de incertidumbre y de
discusión es algo digno de lo que han
sido las divisiones que marcaron a esta
legislatura pero con 92 votos a favor y
ninguno en contra los parlamentarios se
pusieron fin al gobierno de natal y
bennett y fijaron el primero de
noviembre como fecha para las próximas
elecciones en las quintas en tres años y
medio así primo la postura del
oficialismo frente a una oposición que
prefería el 25 de octubre como fecha de
los comicios víctimas de los
estancamientos quedaron dos proyectos de
ley clave para la coalición saliente uno
era el que permitía avanzar hacia la
exención de visados para ir realidades
que viajen a eeuu y el otro era el que
permitía también avanzar en el sistema
de metro para tel aviv y alrededores
pero a tiempo cuando llegó la disolución
en para extender de manera automática
las normas de emergencia que permiten la
aplicación de la ley civil israelí a los
colonos judíos en los asentamientos en
cisjordania cuya amenaza de no
aprobación fue lo que terminó forzando
del gobierno hasta que se forme un nuevo
ejecutivo el centrista yair lapid actual
ministro de exteriores- asumirá como
primer ministro interino legalmente a
partir de la medianoche en reemplazo de
benet quien se mantendrá como
alternativo y no buscará su reelección
según informó anoche con la que necesite
solo convocable bajo circunstancias
excepcionales en la pide tendrá poco
margen de maniobra para cambios pero
deberá mantener a flote el ejecutivo y
ya tiene programado su primer viaje
internacional será la próxima semana a
francia para reunirse con el presidente
en manuel macro